字幕: Moe Serizawa
校正: Koichiro Yoda
皆さんこんにちは
川嶋一実です
今日はみなさんに
「飛びこむ力」で自分の道を切り開く
方法についてお話しします
理想の未来を引き寄せる魔法
それが「飛びこむ力」です
私は大学卒業後 製薬会社に入社し
働きながら国内外で女優をしています
以前 テレビドラマに起用してくれた
映画プロデューサーに
入社したことを報告しました
すると彼はこう言いました
「じゃあ 今後は 女優は無理だね」
私は心の中で呟きます
「誰が決めたの？ そんなこと
難しい道なのは分かってる
でも 私は ビジネスと表現の世界
その２つをおもいっきりサバイブしたい
自分なりのやり方で」
そう決めました
そうして20代を過ごして
後半になってきたときのことです
信頼する映画監督との飲み会でのことでした
映画監督が私にこう言うんです
「一実ちゃんさあ
一実ちゃんだから
売れてほしいから言うんだけど
整形してみたらどう？」
「えっ？」
「いや だから 整形手術
顔変えるんだよ」
ひどいと思いません？
それを２時間ずーっと聞かされて
「今 売れるのは
美女かブスのどっちかだから
だからどっちかになれよ
でもブスになるの嫌でしょ？
じゃあ 絶世の美女になりなよ」って
「あぁ そっかー
この人は 私のために
わざわざ厳しいことを言ってくれてるんだ」
そう理解することにして
納得しようとしました
でも 日が経つとなんだか心が疼きます
「あぁ どうしちゃったんだろう 私」
そういうふうに思って
自分の心の中に問いかけてみました
「認めたくないけれど
本当は傷ついていたんだな」
そう感じる自分がいました
「どうしたらいいんだろう？ このモヤモヤ
受け入れるべきなのか」
その監督の言うことを聞いたと思います？
私は 「No」でした
「じゃあ 自分なりに どういうふうな
設計をするの？ これからの人生」
「こんなにモヤモヤする気持ちなんだから
これを糧にして
なんとか自分の生き方を探そう」
そして 閃いたんです
「私は 自分の生き方で勝負しよう」って
「冒険の旅に出て 新しい何かを探そう
そうだ ニューヨークに行ったら
何か見つかるかもしれない」
私の初めての海外旅行はニューヨークでした
あの街に行ったなら何か見つかるかもしれない
これから映画も作りたいし
舞台も海外で出演したい
そんな想いがふつふつ湧いてきました
「よし これは行くしかない！」
そう思って 会社の上司に言いました
「すいません ちょっとお休みください」
そして ニューヨークに
飛びこむことに決めたんです
その出発日が 2011年3月12日でした
前日は 震災に見舞われ
東京のオフィスに閉じ込められました
翌日になって
東京は交通が麻痺しています
私はなんとか空港に着きました
そして ニューヨークに旅立ちました
ニューヨークに飛びこんでみると
大好きだったミュージシャンの
スタジオを訪ねることができたり
映画事務所に遊びに行くことができます
「テレビで見てたアーティストと
仲良くなることができるんだ！」
すっごくびっくりしました
そうして どんどん友達が増えていくので
半年に１回ニューヨークに行くようになりました
その中で 同世代の演劇人と出会います
彼女は日本人で
アメリカの劇団でパフォーマーをしていました
私たちは意気投合します
彼女は私を「ひーちゃん」と呼ぶんです
「ねえねえ ひーちゃん ひーちゃん」
楽しげに 色んなことを教えてくれるんです
アメリカでの生活のことを
ある日彼女はこう言いました
「ひーちゃん 今度ね フィラデルフィアで
ニューヨークのアクターたちを呼び寄せて
リハーサルをするんだ」
「えっ？リハーサルって何？」
私がそう尋ねると彼女は言います
「即興で舞台を作るの
色んなシーンをね 実験的に作るの」
「そうなんだ」
私がニューヨークに行ったのは
ニューヨークの演劇人が
どんなふうに舞台を作るんだろうっていう
そんな好奇心で行ったので
私は その好奇心を止められないまま
彼女に聞きました
「ねえ もしよかったら
その現場を見学させてもらえない？」
彼女は うーんと考えて言います
「ごめん 初顔合わせのメンバーなの
それに実験的な試みなの
だから ちょっと難しいかもしれない
でも 考えてみるね！」
「ありがとう」
可能性があるかどうかは別として
その可能性を考えてくれる彼女に感謝しました
そうして 毎日毎日
ニューヨークでの日々が過ぎていきます
そして 彼女からまた電話がきました
「ひーちゃん 私の演出助手っていう形でさあ
フィラデルフィアの
リハーサルに来てくれない？
その方がやりがいあるでしょう？」
彼女は場を用意してくれました
「うん 分かった！どうしたらいいの？」
私が尋ねると 彼女はこう言います
「フィラデルフィアまでは
二ューヨークからバスで来て
そのバスには 俳優たちと一緒に来てね
朝７時の便で」
「うんうん 分かった」
そう言って電話を切り
その日を待ち遠しく待ちます
そしてリハーサルの前日です
彼女が電話かけてきました
なんだか様子が変です
「もしもし どうしたの？」
「私 昨日の夜 脚折っちゃったの」
「えっ？脚折っちゃったって
今どういう状態なの？」
「松葉杖ついてんの
動けないことないけど明日どうするか
すっごく悩んでるんだ」
そう彼女が言います
それは大変だ
でも すごく開催を迷ってるから
私は素直に気持ちを伝えることにしました
「あのね 私の気持ちを伝えるね
私としてはどんなサポートもするから
リハーサル開いてほしいな」
そう言うと彼女は
「うん分かった！じゃあさ 悪いんだけど
一足早く１人でフィラデルフィアに
来てくれる？ 朝６時の便で」
「もちろん オッケー！」
そう言って私は電話を切りました
そしてその夜は
映画人との飲み会があって
深夜まで飲んでいました
急いでアパートに帰って
仮眠をとって 朝４時に目覚めます
おっとっと まずいまずい
６時の ６時のバス ６時のバス・・・
そう思ってPCを開いて
６時のバスを検索します
あれ？ ６時のバスなんて
そもそもないじゃん！
ある って言うからあるもんだと思って
行く前に調べれればいいと思って
そう思ってたら何にもない
えっ？ どうしよう？
私 フィラデルフィアの
どこに行けばいいんだ？
そう思って 色々検索をしてみます
今までもらったメールを見てみると
どこにも行き先が書いてなかったんです
そうだ 私ニューヨークのアクターたちに
連れて行ってもらう約束だったから
場所を聞かされてなかったんだ
これはまずいぞ
しかも 朝の４時 誰も起きてない
え？ フィラデルフィア？
フィラデルフィアって一体どこなんだ？
えっ？ 州なの？ 街なの？
大きさは？ 全然分からない
イメージが掴めないんです
「もう どうしよう どうしよう
本当に怖い」と思って
でも 約束守りたいし
っていうか現場を見たいし
そういうワクワクする気持ちも抑えられない
こういう時 皆さんならどうします？
連絡待ちますか？
連絡待とうかなと思ったんですけど
でも 早く行きたいから
うーん どうしよう
「フィラデルフィア」って
着く所に行けばいいのかな
そう思って なんとなく駅の方に行きました
そして色んな人に聞いて聞いて
アムトラックっていうその電車が
フィラデルフィアに行くらしいことを
突き止めます
飛び乗って 運よく彼女が
電話をかけてくれたらいいな
そう願いながら電車に飛び乗ると
彼女から電話がかかってきました
「ひーちゃんごめん
そうだ６時のバスなんてないよね
見ずに言っちゃったよ
今どこにいんの？」
「アムトラックの中
この電車で合ってるのかな？」
そう彼女に聞くと
「うんうん それに乗って
今から最寄りの駅を言うから
そこで降りて そしてタクシーに乗って
スタジオまで来て」
「分かった」
私は彼女が教えてくれた住所をもとに
タクシーに乗って そして
スタジオに辿り着きます
スタジオの階段を駆け上がる
そしてスタジオに入ると
彼女がウワーっと走ってきます
松葉杖をつきながら
「ひーちゃん 待ってた
ごめんね でも来れたね」
「うん よかった」
「じゃあこれから 準備始めよう」
そう言って私たちは準備を始めます
彼女の指示にしたがって
音響の音を流して 照明で照らして
そして たまに撮影をする
そうやってリハーサルに没頭していると
彼女がこう言いました
「ひーちゃん 後半のシーンからはさ
ひーちゃんも役者として入ってみなよ」
「え？ いいの？
あ でもさ 私 英語話せないんだけど？」
「いいよいいよ 言葉なんて
感情は言葉を超えるからやってみなよ！」
「うん 分かった！」
そう言ってステージの方に向かいながら
「あれ？ でも どうすればいいんだろう？」
でも 始まっちゃう
ステージの前にノープランで立ちます
「よーい スタート！」
シーンが始まります
私たちに与えられたテーマは
「相手役から欲しい物を取る
あとは何でもいいから
即興でシーンを作ってね」
そんな漠然としたテーマで
即興をやることになりました
相手役を見ると
彼の指にはキラリと光る指輪がありました
「あぁ あの薬指に光る指輪綺麗だなあ」
そう思って彼に言いました
「その指輪をほしいんだけど お願い」
「えっ？ これ結婚指輪だから
無理だよ あげられない」
「いやいや 本当に欲しいの
あなたが大切にしてるものが欲しいの」
そう言うと彼は
「いやいや ちょっと待ってくれよ」
と言って逃げるんです
私は本気で追いかけて 彼は逃げて
そうやって 本気の
追いかけっこをしているうちに
会場中がみんな笑いの渦になりました
「はーい おしまい！」
シーンは終わります
「なんだか今日はいい一日だった」
最初は 無口なアジア人だったと
思うんです 私
でも 最後は アメリカ人の俳優たちに
溶け込むことができた
そうウキウキしながら歩いていると
今度は演出の彼女が言います
「ねえ 今度は一緒に作品を作ろうね」
「うん！いつかそんな日が来るといいね」
そう言って私たちは別れました
そして半年後 彼女から電話がかかってきます
「ひーちゃん フィラデルフィアで
作品を作るけど来られる？」
「うん 会社と日程調整するから
でも 絶対行くから待ってて」
そう言って 私は詳細を聞かないまま
またアメリカに旅立ちました
「アメリカ着いたよー！」
彼女に電話します
彼女は言います
「あっ ごめんごめん 伝え忘れてた
主演は あなた
そしてタイトルは『HITOMI』
頑張ってね！」
「そうなんだ
私 出演できるだけじゃなくて主演なんだ」
すごく驚きながら
またフィラデルフィアに向かいます
彼女の創作は すごく珍しいやり方で
即興でシーンをまた築いていく
そして その面白かったシーンを繋いで
一つの物語を作っていきます
彼女が与えたテーマはこんなことでした
「大震災 その直後に—
私たちが感じる
本当のセキュリティとは何か」
そんなお題を出されました
アメリカ人の俳優も 私も
みんなそれぞれ 俳優の体から
内側から出てくる表現を精一杯出します
そして 彼女が引き上げてシーンを作っていく
そうして作られたシーンは
東京のビジネスウーマンが震災にあい
そして 揺れ動くオフィスの中で
机の中に潜っていて
四つん這いになって 這って出てみると
福島に降り立った牛になっていた
そんなシーンから始まります
そして アメリカに旅立ち
色々な人と巡り会う
人との巡り合いってすっごくいいねっていう
そんな 私のこれまでの旅が色濃く出た
そんな作品でした
ニューヨークへ旅立つときに
応援してくれる人も沢山いました
でも 訝しげに
「え 何しに行くの？」
「ツテないんでしょう？」
「人に会うって 何言ってんの？
変な人」って
そんな視線が痛くて痛くて
理由を[聞か]れても
「うーん だって
行きたいから行くんだけど」
その一言でしか返せませんでした
私が主演をして帰ってくると
みんなが祝福をしてくれます
そういうふうに冷ややかだった人も
それで思ったんです
「ああ 人の言うことっていうのは
結構あてにならないものだなあ
本当に大切なことは
自分の心がよく知っていて
自分の心に問いかけてみるべきなんだ」
そう思いました
小学校１年生のときの話をします
小学校１年生の担任の先生は
要領のいい子が大好きな人でした
要領のいい子がなんとなく教室と
そして先生の空気を読んで
チャチャっと何か物事をやるような
そんな子が活躍するような教室に
私は馴染めませんでした
先生からは「あなたは 遅い
マイペース 和を乱す」
そう言われ続けると私も萎縮して
仲間から外れて
何も言葉を交わすことができなくなりました
ある日の道徳の時間
先生が指差して言います
「あなた 何も発言しないけど
何か言ってみなさい」
おずおずと立つけど
何も言葉が出てきません
「言いたいことがあるはずなのに
何も浮かばない
どうしたらいいんだろう？」
そうして突っ立っていると
彼女がやってきます
「意見のない子はここに必要ないから
出て行ってちょうだい」
そう言って彼女は教室から引っ張り出します
「先生 お願いだから
この教室にいさせてください
私 廊下に一人で出るなんて嫌です」
蚊の鳴くような声で彼女に訴えても
「みんなと同じことができないなら
外に出てなさい」そう言いました
一部始終を両親に伝えました
すると 両親はこう言いました
「そんな学校なんて行かなくていいわよ」
「え？ 行かない選択なんてあるの？」
両親は 私の心に寄り添ってくれました
そのことに今でもすごく感謝しています
でも もし行かなかったら
外の世界との繋がりが薄れてしまう
もう外の世界なんて出られないような気がして
だから 私はなんとか
学校に行くようにしたんです
重いランドセルを背負って
毎日毎日 学校へ一人で行きます
そうしてある日
２年生になって運よく
担任の先生が替わります
学期末を迎えると通信簿が配られますよね
恐る恐る開いてみる
すると新しい先生の言葉はこうでした
「あなたは 丁寧に真面目に
物事に取り組みますね
その姿勢を大切にしてください」
そのとき思ったことがあります
「大人だからって
正しいっていうわけじゃないんだな
評価というのは人それぞれで
意見というのは主観なんだ」
そんなふうに思いました
今 こうして やっと自由に
何かをやれるようになった
それでもやっぱり恐怖心はあります
これから向かいたい先
うーんと考えると
そうだ 私は今度 映画作りに
挑戦したいんだと思いました
本当にやりたいことだから
チャレンジするのはすっごく怖い
でも また私は えいやと
飛びこんでみようと思います
いつだって 挑戦の可能性はある
私はそう信じています
もし みなさんの中に何か想いがあって
でも まだ形にならない
だけどやってみたい
そういう想いがあるのなら
ぜひ 飛びこんでみてください
それが周りに理解されなくても
きっと道は開けます
あなたらしい 私らしい きらめく
そんな生き方を手に入れましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）